one two three I have a question for you
what so last year actually for the past
two years we always fight every year we
have this massive fight about how I
don't think it's a good idea to leave
bird food out in the balcony and just
spread them all over like this that's
the thing because he wants her cats to
have entertainment so he gets like a big
bag of bird food and he just does that
where they always sit right there by the
window yeah that's kind of nice um
except that Ming has literally hung off
the balcony just to catch a [ __ ] bird
she's caught she'd brought dead birds in
like so many [ __ ] lesson to you right
now so my question sir to you my
question to you sir is why the [ __ ] is
there bird seeds all over the [ __ ]
balcony again because something you [ __ ]
okay that I'm I'm a man with ears eyes
and I have I have opinions and I and I
absorb information I'm a human being
okay yeah and I googled once right that
cat's looking through the window to see
Birds is a good thing right it gives
them entertainment yeah I mean it gives
them that drive you know man that like
hunting drive which makes them happy you
know I mean yeah it's that when goon or
goes and tries to search for food when I
already have food out there it's a part
of his that's animal make literally the
complete opposite of what I've
experienced with my cats in when I used
my two cats in the past yeah that's
first of all karate and the other one
Marley I don't know them and to me
they're not my cat I'll give a [ __ ] what
they were like it's the thing where if
they can't get to the birds they end up
putting their frustration yeah because
you're healthy shitty cat
they've never done that not yet no they
won't
cuz I always cry I am a they know I'm a
nature man my cats look at me they know
I'm a nature man right and I'm connected
to the world but through my energy yeah
right I'm a catch I'm connected the
trees to the planet Earth you know we're
all brothers and sisters and we're all
connected and they [ __ ] get that [ __ ]
right because I'm their father or their
leader okay and so they know that what
I'm doing right
is out of love and they get it right
your to other cats didn't I wasn't in
their lives as an influence right so
they didn't get you know grade-a [ __ ]
food and like sashimi and share this
crazy food because we know we're going
through that we're like holy [ __ ]
there's some nice but it's about two
hundred dollars a week just on cats yeah
you know no I sometimes just throw it
away if they don't like it I thought it
would literally there's like frozen like
rabbit like rabbit paws you know you got
to try it true yeah
every if you see their little cat tree
outside it's always just like a it's
like it's like a Vegas buffet yeah yeah
yeah like for instance there's just new
cat food called rad cat it's a raw rat
cat food for cats obviously and it's
very human I was wrong it's very
difficult to find right so I had to go
to North Hollywood you found it and I
went I found it about like eight things
of it and you thought in the
refrigerator how much is one twenty
dollars or something Wow it's
interesting so I thought one I put it in
the thing and my three Castle stared at
it and they just kind of walked away
like [ __ ] you
so you have just eight cans of $20 cash
you know we could probably eat at you
and hug that good yeah it's probably
really [ __ ] the greatest reviews in
every review they said our cats too
obsessed with this I give it to my cats
and just kind of look like that because
you know that it's because my cats are
are evolved and they're no you didn't I
did not do that I don't treat my like
cats like they're animals I treat my
cats like they're an extension of me mmm
and they're extension of bobbili and
what I like and what I like is I like to
go to nice restaurants and I like nice
food okay and my cats whatever is the
best thing on the market is they're
gonna get it the best toy laser toy
anything they're gonna get it everything
great a cuz I love them
okay and that's what it is and if you
you have cats and you don't do that you
don't love them that much
[Music]